[Music]
hi everyone i'm allison wagenfeld with
google cloud welcome to google cloud
next and thank you to our google
orchestra composed of bay area googlers
we are coming to you live from our
google cloud campus in silicon valley
where i'm here with sundar pachai and
thomas curion we have an incredible
lineup over the next three days with
live keynotes demos and q a with our
leadership and over 140 sessions
covering all our cloud solutions
our customers and partners will share
how they're using google cloud in google
workspace technology to tackle their
greatest challenges and opportunities we
are humbled to support their work and
share their stories
thank you for being here with us
and now please join me in welcoming
google and alphabet ceo sundar pachai
hi everyone
welcome to google cloud next
2021
we are happy you're here
of course i'd be happier if he could
actually be here in person
don't get me wrong thomas is great
company
but he still doesn't laugh at my
container jokes
so while many of us are still waiting
for a return to normal
it does feel like we are on our way
the question is will we recognize normal
when we get there
the pandemic has sped up digitization in
all aspects of our lives it's changed
how we visit a doctor
how our kids learn in school
and how we connect with one another
and it's made the future of work our
present
giving us renewed opportunity to
transform our organizations
from our work with customers
thomas and i have learned there are
three things that position us
to be most helpful to businesses
first our cloud platform
it's designed to help enterprises
transform through digitization
built on the deep investments we've made
in technical infrastructure over the
past 23 years
looking at our networking and data
center investments alone
we have the largest network with the
lowest latency of any cloud provider
with our expansions into warsaw delhi
melbourne and toronto this year we now
have 28 regions with plans for 10 more
and it's all connected by 19 subsea
cables
a gracehopper transatlantic cable will
be the first to incorporate novel
optical fiber switching
second our enterprise customers benefit
from our consumer scale and innovation
we have a deep and broad consumer
ecosystem of devices and services
youtube connects a global community of
viewers and
creators android nest assistant and maps
are loved by people around the world
we have the unique ability to connect
consumer ecosystems with enterprise
ecosystems
for example the realistic voices in
language understanding that powers
google assistant
can improve enterprise customer
experiences and increase satisfaction
and the underlying visual technology
that enables google lens to help people
shop
or learn about a new flower in their
garden
can help manufacturers identify defects
third we offer comprehensive security
that helps organizations including ours
protect what matters
security is foundational to everything
we do
we have a long history of building it
into every layer of the computing
environment
we are a pioneer of zero trust computing
and have deep experience running this
model at scale
on its own any one of these pillars
would be helpful to customers
put together they can be transformative
which is the mission of google cloud
we continue to drive innovation through
our products
over the past year we've had more than
1500 product and feature releases
that's about four a day
they're all designed to be helpful
from smart canvas in google workspace
that makes collaboration richer
to new ai powered industry solutions
and bigquery omni for data analytics
across any cloud
we've also made significant partnership
announcements for example we teamed up
with global telecom leaders such as
ericsson
nokia and t-systems to deliver 5g edge
and hosted computing solutions
what i'm most excited about is how our
strengths in cloud
consumer and security are helping top
enterprises
accelerate their transformation
ford chose google as their
transformation partner
because of our strength in consumer and
cloud
together we are innovating in
electrification
connectivity and self-driving
technologies
ford is harnessing google maps to help
drivers navigate
google assistant to help drivers
concentrate
on google play to keep passengers
learning and entertain
l'oreal partnered across google to build
a virtual try on experience
they are harnessing the best ai models
as well as using youtube to build a
community of fans
and google shopping to make it easy to
discover and buy their products
we are humble that so many organizations
continue to put their trust in google
cloud
and we are committed to helping you
solve the biggest challenges you face
i'll be back a little later to talk more
about how we do that
but first i'll turn the stage over to
thomas korean ceo of google cloud to
talk more about our mission
thank you sundar
hello everyone
it's a pleasure to be here on google's
silicon valley campus
today for the moment we all look forward
to all year long
the opportunity to connect with you
our customers partners and developers
and to share all the amazing exciting
stuff we've been working on
a special thank you to all our sponsors
especially our luminary sponsors
accenture otto's maven wave and deloitte
let's first hear from some of our
customers about the amazing ways in
which they have accelerated
transformation with google cloud
[Music]
the pandemic really did accelerate the
digital wave of change by easily three
to five years
[Music]
we transitioned to all virtual care
we're better positioned to accelerate
fast forward to today we have a truly
profound permanent structural
transformation now our team can look at
hundreds of calls in minutes instead of
weeks
our business has really been transformed
with the help of google cloud we have
spikes in demand we can scale four times
in less than five minutes
schroedinger is transforming the way
scientists are developing drugs chemical
space is almost infinite we can do
things we couldn't do before can't i
just track my shipment we think that we
can help solve that for the supply chain
how can we help workers with artificial
intelligence suddenly lots of ideas
become interesting we're very excited to
develop our artificial intelligence and
machine learning access to innovation
the speed of innovation seconds
milliseconds all matter we're rethinking
routine and pioneering simplicity the
partnership with google cloud provides
us with technology that will drive us to
be better
[Music]
now it's not a secret that many of the
biggest and most innovative technology
companies leaders such as spotify
twitter shopify mikado libre sharechat
dapper labs and so many other exciting
startups and tech leaders
choose google cloud to help them build
scale and innovate
still other customers are transforming
using our purpose-built industry
solutions
the home depot for instance use contact
center ai to reduce customer resolution
time by 91 million minutes
procter gamble creates personalized
omni-channel journeys from over
275 million consumer records
ikea retail use recommendations ai to
increase e-commerce click-through rates
by 30 percent
and increase order value by two percent
f i h a foxconn company
used visual inspection to identify
defects
10 times more accurately
mr cooper a leading mortgage services
provider
used document ai to process mortgage
documents
400 percent more efficiently
and bank of new york mellon
developed a liquidity solution that
predicts nearly 40 percent
of security settlement failures with 90
percent accuracy
we're helping many businesses
drive durable innovation
through long-term partnerships with
google's transformation cloud
now to help them transform we focus on
five key themes
one
are we the best at understanding and
using data in an industry
two
do we have the industry's leading
technology infrastructure
three are we creating the best hybrid
workplace for our passionate and
talented employees
four
do we know that our data
systems
and users are secure now
and that they will be secure in the
future
and five
are we working together to address the
most important challenges facing our
world today
we help organizations address these
important questions
let's start with the first question are
we the best at understanding and using
data in an industry
we help organizations unify their data
across multiple clouds and silos
combining structured and unstructured
data and making data every employee's
superpower
using data analytics and ai together
schrodinger accelerated clinical drug
discovery by 60 percent
finding new breakthroughs faster
like many states around the united
states the wisconsin department of
workforce development confronted a wave
of new unemployment claims
using google's data cloud they clear
over
750 000 unemployment claims
reducing claim times from weeks to just
days
and dispersing over 2 billion in
unemployment benefits
walmart is transforming the experience
for the approximately 220 million
shoppers
around the globe who visit a walmart
store
club or e-commerce website each week
i'm honored today to welcome suresh
kumar executive vice president
walmart's global chief technology
officer and chief development officer
hi thomas and hello everyone
i'm excited to be here today to share
about how we at walmart are innovating
on behalf of our customers
our associates and the role that our
partners like you google have played in
our innovation journey
now i came to walmart at a time of
incredible digital transformation and
jointly with my team created a robust
execution plan to accelerate the
transformation across three areas
building great customer experiences
optimizing our business and modernizing
our platform and our infrastructure
each of these three priorities are
individually important but when you
bring them together
at the scale of a business like walmart
it has a massive impact if you move with
speed
you can completely transform global
operations
and disrupt entire industries
some of our most data intensive or
critical decisioning process
are getting the big query treatment
through this not only are we seeing
significant savings that will continue
as we migrate more and more data over we
are also seeing the ability to use the
data in interesting ways
including enabling analytics at scale
and turning data into actionable
insights from a data migration to
bigquery
standpoint 97 percent of the tables used
for data vectors have already migrated
to the cloud
and 30 of the big data have been
migrated with plans to almost double
that by the end of this fiscal year
and the cherry on the top
is that bigquery has allowed us to
integrate with pretty much any data
visualization tool and analytics tool
that's out there
thereby improving our processing time by
23 percent and of course needless to say
a much better user experience
using bigquery has had a direct impact
on our business
an excellent example is our ability to
close our financial books in three days
instead of five days
and that's a pretty big deal
leveraging our cloud
has enabled us to unleash the potential
of ai across our entire business
this goes from predicting demand to
managing
in-stock levels to optimizing supply
chain to freeing up time for our
associates to serve our customers
as one example express delivery which is
our two hour delivery service which we
launched last year
actively uses ai behind the scenes as
the customer is
creating that order
multiple algorithms work in munition
to optimize the delivery route
and determine if the customer is
eligible for express delivery we are
building our own ai and ml capabilities
to power multiple areas of our business
including classification natural
language processing forecasting
regression computer vision predictions
process automations and a whole lot more
so to wrap up
i'm really excited about the opportunity
walmart has to drive innovation and to
further disrupt the retail industry
i hope
you will agree that our work together
is making a huge difference for our
customers and our associates
thank you for having me
thank you suresh
you know tens of thousands of incredible
organizations like walmart
choose google's data cloud for four
reasons
first google's data cloud is the most
complete and unified data and ai
platform to help you manage every stage
of the data life cycle
from running operational transactions to
developing analytical applications
we help customers unify data lakes and
warehouses as data lake houses
to reduce complexity
and to combine structured and
unstructured data built in data science
and ai with support for mapreduce spark
and presto enables continuous learning
and experimentation
and we support real time streaming
that natively uses open source standards
like beam and flink
google's data cloud is also unmatched
for speed
scale
security and reliability
bigquery one of the most successful and
beloved data warehouse solutions
with its unique serverless approach
during a typical week
helps more than 3000 different
organizations
analyze more than 200 petabytes of data
and thousands of customers use data proc
to run spark and hadoop clusters easily
spanner a fully managed relational
database with unlimited scale
and multi-zone and multi-region
consistency
serves more than 1
billion requests per second
and provides a 5 9 sla
google data cloud's vertex ai
offers the ai pioneered at google
research and deep mind so that every
data scientist and ml engineer
can now build deploy and scale ai models
faster
and with 80 percent less code using ai
the same way google does
for instance ge appliances an appliance
manufacturing leader for more than a
century
is using google cloud including ai the
edge to build innovative digital
products
with over-the-air updates
finally google's data cloud is more open
standards based
you can choose from postgres mysql
redis mongodb
or migrate from oracle or sql server
and we have strategic partners
with leading data driven applications
for instance
c3ai has made its entire lineup
of ai-based applications available on
google cloud
our customers can analyze
govern
and visualize data from many databases
and storage system
on google
or other clouds
including all of google's databases
google sheets
and bigquery
using looker a premier bi and embedded
analytics solution
you know today
we're thrilled and excited to announce
that we'll be integrating tableau
a leader in data visualization with
looker
google sheets and bigquery
tableau customers will soon be able to
use looker's semantic model
enabling new levels of data governance
and access to data
let's take a look at this alex over to
you
thank you thomas in this demo we're
going to show you how you can seamlessly
use looker and tableau together to
answer your critical business questions
let's say i work at an e-commerce
company in our looker model provides a
consistent view across the organization
for our most important business metrics
here for example you can see the
definition for gross margin
our looker dashboard is based on that
same semantic model since it provides
trusted insights at a glance i can
immediately see that sales are up
however did i miss anything let's find
out
say i'm more comfortable working in
spreadsheets i can now take advantage of
the new integration between looker and
google sheets
with a couple of clicks i have access to
my governed and trusted looker data in
sheets and i can easily connect to my
data models
to understand which factors are
impacting sales i'll drag and drop
fields from my model into a pivot table
to break out sales by category over time
since it's pulling from looker i can
trust that all the data definitions are
consistent i can use familiar sheets
formulas and formatting to get insights
faster and understand how specific
products are selling
we see a notable downward trend month
over month for activewear i want to
share these findings with my marketing
team who's using tableau
now i can use the new tableau and looker
integration to combine data for my
looker data model with marketing data to
build a more comprehensive view of my
business
next i'm going to plot sales by category
and then add marketing spend to the view
tableau makes it easy for me to drill
down on relevant data now i can see that
social marketing spend was significantly
lower for activewear and this is why
there's a downward trend in activewear
sales
i'm going to publish this result on
tableau online and tag my marketing team
so they can take action
leveraging integrations between tableau
sheets and looker allows our teams to
build powerful visualizations using
trusted data we can then share these
visualizations throughout our
organization to drive informed decisions
action and impact back over to you
thomas
thank you alex
the second questions customers ask
do we have industry-leading technology
infrastructure
we're experiencing great momentum with
our open infrastructure cloud
many of the most demanding and
technically advanced customers in the
world
disproportionately choose us
take for example leading media companies
and streaming services such as univision
and global the largest media group in
latin america
they use our high performance networking
computing and storage to broadcast media
including live events
such as the recent tokyo olympics
leading telecommunications companies are
also choosing google cloud reliance geo
the world's second largest mobile
carrier is automating its 5g network
vodafone is processing over a billion
network events each day
at t
is delivering new multi-access edge
computing solutions
and telus is migrating critical i t and
network workloads
all to google cloud
you know leading data management
companies including data bricks redis
cockroach labs couch-based elastic
influx data mariadb mongodb
neo4j and single store
are all growing faster on google cloud
than on any other cloud
and they love
our storage scalability and advanced
infrastructure mongodb for instance
has more net new customers
via google cloud marketplace
than on any other cloud
leading cyber security companies such as
palo alto networks
exuberant fy shape splunk broadcom and
forgerock
are also choosing google cloud for its
performance global scale and underlying
security
customers are migrating and transforming
sap
and vmware workloads to google cloud
in just the last year we've added three
times the number of sap customers
as the prior year
and were exhilarating
paypal for instance has an sap hana
scale out system
supporting 40 million business
transactions daily
200 billion records
touched in just 30 seconds
mitel in canada
migrated over 1 000
vmware virtual machines in less than 90
days
to google cloud vmware engine
nilas
an api platform company
chose our tile virtual machines
along with google kubernetes engine
as they saw over 40 percent better price
performance than in a competitor
you know customers choose our open cloud
infrastructure
for three main reasons
first
we make your path to migrate and
modernize using cloud
easy
with migration tools
new serverless and container
capabilities
and managed services
as your developers spend more time
building experiences
that your customers love
second we offer transformative
capabilities with cutting edge
performance and security
and our network offers
three times the throughput of other
cloud providers
third we remain
and were the very first
and only cloud provider
with a clear
multi-cloud strategy
we provide you with a consistent
developer experience
built an open source to write once and
deploy anywhere
many customers like plaid a financial
services leader
use antos to deploy
operate and manage applications across
multiple clouds
recently we introduced anthos for
virtual machines
standardizing the way that you manage
applications across both virtual
machines and containers
for multi-cloud data
bigquery omni
lets customers analyze data
across google cloud
aws
migrate data
customers also want to expand where they
use google cloud
whether in their private data centers or
out on the edge
for instance some workloads cannot move
to the public cloud entirely
due to the need for large amounts of
local data processing
extremely low latency or strict
regulations
to solve these challenges we're
announcing today
google distributed cloud
a portfolio of hardware and software
solutions that extend our infrastructure
to the edge
and even into your own data center
to tell you more about it
please welcome inez from our google
cloud distributed cloud team
thank you thomas
google distributed cloud is a set of
fully managed services running on google
managed hardware based on open apis and
built on antos it gives customers
greater deployment flexibility and
ensures more consistent operations
across hybrid and multi-cloud
environments more than any other cloud
provider there are four deployment
scenarios depending on your specific
needs
google's network edge this allows
customers to leverage over 140 network
edge locations around the world
operator adds this scenario is designed
to accommodate emerging services and
applications with a stringent latency
and reliability requirements for a
specific operator customer ads this
scenario supports customer owned edge
locations such as retail stores factory
floors or branch offices which require
localized compute and processing and
finally customer data centers this
deployment option is specific to
customer owned data centers and color
facilities google distributed cloud also
includes a hosted mode to run sensitive
workloads and address data sovereignty
security and privacy requirements it
does not require connectivity to google
cloud at any time to manage
infrastructure services apis or tooling
you have the choice to manage it
yourself or host through a designated
trusted partner
back to you thomas
thank you ines
partners like hpe
dell cisco and netapp are key as we
deploy google distributed cloud globally
on best-in-class hardware
i'm pleased to announce the expansion of
our partnership with network appliance
in two important ways
first netapp is our primary partner
supporting google's distributed cloud
storage infrastructure
second for customers using google cloud
vmware engine
they now have preview access for netapp
cloud volumes
we are the only hyperscaler to provide
customers with this choice
deep partnerships with t-systems and
tolus
have also enabled us to address the
evolving
sovereignty requirements for cloud
technology in germany and france
the next question we hear
is how can we provide the best
environment to help employees create
and innovate together especially in a
hybrid workplace you know hybrid is
redefining how we all work
making it less about where we work
but more about the quality of our
experience
studies estimate that more than 48
percent of employees will work remotely
post covet
google workspace
is the best platform for hybrid work
with simple
powerful
and secure tools to help people
communicate and collaborate with one
another no matter where they are
we introduce smart canvas
to help content creators remove friction
from workflows
and enable teams to stay connected
outside of meetings to foster well-being
and reduce video call fatigue
we made communication and collaboration
completely seamless
for instance
users can easily present and collaborate
in meetings
create meeting notes from their calendar
present and meet directly from doc
sheets or slides and collaborate
directly from chat and spaces
we optimize collaboration from all
mobile devices
to provide great experiences
for frontline workers who make up 80
of the global workforce
one of america's largest hospital
systems common spirit health
is advancing its mission during the
pandemic by making its frontline doctors
and nurses productive with google
workspace
since hybrid work has removed the notion
of a physical location for work
google workspace created spaces
a unified digital location for work
today more than 3 billion users
move securely and seamlessly between
mail
chat audio video and now spaces
and you too
can choose among the over 5
300
public apps in our marketplace
and you can also add thousands of
private apps
to enhance your workspace
now i want to step aside for just a
minute
and tell you about a hidden secret
in our portfolio products
app sheet
our no code platform that makes it easy
for everyone
not just professional developers
to build amazing apps and workflows
for instance property managers at
carrefour properties
used appsheet
to build a mobile app
to log track and resolve problems with
headquarters
replacing a multi-step manual process
we're also partnering with citrix
because employees sometimes need access
to windows and mac os applications and
desktops
directly served from the cloud
we're expanding our partnership with
citrix today to deliver an integrated
desktop as a service solution
purpose built on google cloud
now customers ask us
do we know that our data systems and
users are secure
and how do we keep them secure
in the future
you know as more digital users access
more data from more locations
the risk of cyber security breaches is
exhilarating
by pioneering new approaches to security
google keeps more people safe online
than anyone else in the world
take for instance jetblue
it's keeping its system secure
protecting the data of all its travelers
and modernizing its security operations
using chronicle
to detect threats
across petabytes of security telemetry
eliminating data blind spots
commence bank
one of germany's largest banks
is using our new certificate authority
service
to verify machine
and workload identity improving security
simplifying operations eliminating
entire classes of threats
secure by default drives customers to
choose google cloud
first we've implemented zero trust at
the core of our services and our
operations enabling you to trust nothing
second we've built cloud scale threat
detection and response allowing you to
detect everything
and third we know it's not just about
tools
we provide the advisory services you
need to transform security operations
we keep customers safe with beyond corp
enterprise which enables zero trust
access for all your users
today we're expanding beyond corp to all
your applications
modern and legacy
web and desktop and even to production
environments
we keep customers safe by eliminating
software supply chain vulnerabilities
over the past two decades
we pioneered an approach to secure our
own software supply chain
we are now making that technology
available
through the salsa open source framework
and as managed services on our cloud to
help you
secure your own software supply chain
we keep customers safe by integrating
chronicles threat detection capability
with our security command center
allowing you to respond faster to
potential risks
and we keep customers safe
by bringing our security expertise to
you
with our google cyber security action
team
a team of our leading security experts
who can help shape your security
transformation
from your very first implementation
through responding to a major incident
and engineering new solutions
as needs change
finally
we continue to expand our security
ecosystem with companies like fortinet
palo alto networks
tallis and so many more
today i'd like to welcome a new security
partner
cyber reason with whom we are
collaborating to deliver a new extended
detection and response offering that
will combine chronicles capability
with cyber reasons mallops engine
for faster easier threat detection and
response
our products
our new cyber security action team and
our partnerships
all make the world safer from cyber
threats
to talk more about how we help keep
each and every one of you secure
and how we're addressing some of the
most important challenges facing our
world
i'd like to invite sundar back
thank you
thank you
thomas
security is top of mind for businesses
of all sizes
as well as the public sector
and despite the progress that has been
made in cyber security
large-scale breaches continue to make
headlines
that's why in august google announced
we'll invest 10 billion dollars over the
next five years to strengthen cyber
security
that includes expanding zero trust
programs
helping secure the software supply chain
and enhancing open source security
a new challenge is keeping collaboration
secure and private as we move to hybrid
work environments
to help we are introducing a new work
safer program
it provides the highest level of
security for your email meetings
messaging and more
and brings together google workspace
with tight and security keys beyond corp
and other secure technologies products
and partners
now every kind of organization and
business can access the same security
protections
that make work safer at google
security is an issue that affects us all
and this brings us to the last question
thomas posed
are we addressing the most important
challenges facing our world
climate change is one of the most
profound challenges we face
it'll take all of us working together to
solve it
sustainability has been a core value for
us for more than two decades
google has been carbon neutral since
2007
and we've matched our operations with
100 renewable energy over four
consecutive years
last year we set out to make our third
decade of climate action
our biggest yet
that included a bold commitment to
operate on 24 7 carbon free energy
across our offices and data centers by
2030
and last week we announced new ways we
are helping one billion people make more
sustainable choices
when it comes to enterprises one of the
most important sustainability choices is
where to run your technology
idc predicts
cloud migrations over the next four
years
could reduce carbon emissions by over 1
billion metric tons
or the equivalent of removing
200 million cars off the road for a year
we are proud that google cloud is the
cleanest cloud in the industry earlier
this year we introduced a way for
customers
to choose the cleanest regions to run
their workloads
today we are expanding our portfolio of
solutions and partnerships to help
reduce your carbon footprint
first we have focused on giving you
greater transparency around carbon
emissions data
we are announcing carbon footprint a new
service to measure
track and report the gross carbon
emissions associated with your google
cloud usage
having this data at your fingertips is
really important
and we know that many customers track
sustainability data in other places
that's why i'm happy to announce that
google cloud emission data will
integrate directly into salesforce
sustainability cloud
we also want to give you the tools to
act on the data
so today we are introducing a new tool
that will alert you when you have idle
workloads and make recommendations to
reduce carbon emissions
it's all part of our goal to help make
your cloud transformation secure and
sustainable
and solve for what's next
so on behalf of thomas and myself
let me thank you once again for trusting
us to be a partner with you on this
journey and we hope you enjoy the next
three days
thank you
[Music]
you